hello I'm gab I'm down where the slow mo
guys a few years ago down I learned
about something called pop Corning yeah
I mean we did a video of popcorn before
now popping the kernels never here this
is slightly different slightly different
it's when a person sometimes unknowingly
sits on an airbag and it goes off and
launches them like halfway to the moon
sometimes I mean usually I'm a fan of
flat pranks and things and I'm usually
up for anything but definitely I'm not
up for this well we've got an air bag
and because you didn't want to do it we
sort of hired a new member of the team
anyway yeah we did so this is to save my
back oh all right this is we've named
him slow-mo yeah mo mo now is up for
anything yeah just in case you know we
weren't already enough like Mythbusters
although this is cheaper than Buster I
think yes yeah definitely so shall we
wire up an air bag and see how he does
so I perched him on this air bag here
curiously careful were you reaching oh
sorry sorry I'm sorry and it's all
hooked up I just need to connect these
two to a car battery and we'll be good
to go on the air bag I hope you survive
yeah this honestly slightly nervous for
him but I've tilted in sort of like a
nice jaunty angle and yeah hopefully
doesn't smash anything on his way up
well he doesn't look scared he doesn't
know you're right in order to not have
mo crush the Phantom we've put the
Phantom under this handy table this
might be the first and last appearance
of mo what are your predictions he's
gonna have a really bad time I think
he's gonna shed limbs in head maybe
hopefully we'll see why I didn't want to
do this yeah I've got a mannequin I
think we'll learn that within the first
point one second of detonation right
we're connected negative three two one
something like a head rolling there you
couldn't pose it there as in like he
looks like he's been blown up like his
arms off
no he's handles smolder his heads off so
do you think he just went up and then
facepalm I think I think we made him
popcorn I wonder how high he went I
wonder if he just went like that looks
uncomfortable it looks painful but I
didn't fling him that far sort of like
he just left the ground I'll be honest
by the way it sounded it I thought it
was gonna be a lot harder than yeah
that's very lackluster oh that's a scar
on the forehead sure I thought you'd
like hit the shelves or something noise
there was I mean even still that's
really cool to see how quickly their
back was out in it alright he didn't
seem to go far did he no he didn't
so trying a different bag yeah trying a
different bag let's try putting it
upside down this time so the air bag
part of it points down rather than up
into him are you ready yep three two one
oh it broke his legs Oh God what's gone
on there where's the air bag gone oh oh
I need to move it how did it go over
there oh did it melt my camera charger I
don't think it did well his ass is
cracked so let's see if we can see how
I think that putting the air bag
downwards actually puts more pressure
into like it wastes the energy on the
air bag fling and I think because his
legs are off frontwards the way the
angle of the air bag comes down just
propels it backwards smashing it right
into all of our charging equipment like
it was like it was almost like the air
bag went alright so this isn't working
as it is in the videos we've seen and I
think the common thread in all the
videos we've watched is that the air bag
is always contained in a chair and if
tire something that stops the air bag
from wasting energy outwards and just
forcing all of it straight up we're
gonna give a bad time on me yeah so I
think I'm gonna describe y'all and get a
tire with which to contain the air bag
and also maybe some bigger air bags
because this passenger one yeah these
ones are steering the one they're gonna
get a passenger one alright it's a new
dawn it's a new day
yeah it's a new copyright strike so
we've gotten one a tire now hopefully
that'll prevent any sort of side spread
edge of the airbag wasted energy the one
that propelled the airbag over there
hopefully that one happened it'll just
send all of the energy up into mo into
mo yeah we've also changed the airbag
we've gone for instead of a steering
wheel one when a passenger side ones
which are potentially bigger because
their airbag has to reach a further
distance oh yes the steering was right
in front of you but then the passenger -
is actually quite far away so usually
bigger airbags yeah usually just more
material yeah do you think the lens is
safe you don't think you'll chuck
something at the glass I don't think it
well okay okay ready yep three two one
Oh rip his arms off Oh Oh he when okay
I'll be honest I think made a difference
I'm beyond estate for a second Lord of
the Rings when they're in Maria and I
think
Peregrin took knocks that bucket over in
his face yeah I feel like a cave trolls
about to bust through the garage door
any second look at this oh my god is
that still gonna work or is it just
gonna be jail that's busted we've got
bits of hand and finger I assume down
here I think it's done for he's done for
it's got a leg off no he's got an entire
leg off which is gone over there and
smashed your batteries yeah we lost a
battery charger his hand landed on the
lens case then what the hand that didn't
explode he's got a leg over here oh look
at that far flip her neck he's gone
every direction
that's not bounce damage is that
explosion that's it I think you blew up
you kidney bat honestly I didn't have
high hopes for the video after the first
couple of attempts disappointing that
cluster yeah like luster is the word
that one is that is that his head oh I
looked it and I saw it cuz it wasn't
there is that like a piece of him that's
brushed against the ceiling I think he's
I think he's done it I think he's hit
the ceiling you know how his hand is
here oh man his feet I go his fingers
everywhere and I didn't know where the
rest of the hand was and this is it it's
like
he lost his thumb his index and his
middle tip yeah I mean you get to see
what did the damage was it him landing
or the explosion oh it does yeah it went
straight up is exactly how the the
tireless work to be honest I zoomed in a
little bit
Oh No Oh
the whole thing came down in the
charging it's okay see look okay there's
a lot going on it the hand didn't smash
on the floor the hand smashed on the
ceiling I think cuz he's already lost
his thumb and fingers yeah yeah there's
the hole wait the other camera was here
as well yeah so I guess it must have
just like missed G be honest I think the
hand were between the two cameras that
was that could have been that was it
irresponsible we thought we'd be safe
with this table here do you think the
lenses safe he'll Chuck something at the
glass I don't think
[Music]
holy crap that was a difference you
turned into a bomb that was mental God
he hit the ceiling he did
I think it's heavy I think I said what
bit hit the light you can see him
bouncing off the ceiling even though
it's out of frame you can see it it
stops him dude I can't believe it in
Dumont
there is no way you could be in the room
with us you would have been it turned
him into shrapnel it did it was
dangerous that could have been so bad
would have been you know an insurance
claim but still not what you want really
not what you want so what happened sir
okay well the blokes have we didn't do
this one outside because it's not good
weather today it's dark it's wet but I
think we actually got a lot out of doing
it in a compressed space like we got
stuff that wouldn't have happened
outside we'd have lost the hand look I'd
have been God not even in the neighbor's
backyard yeah yeah there's a probably a
lake would have disappeared as well all
right let's not do any more there's a
smudge look he's left it was smudge on
this on the wall Oh God yeah that's him
in it yes it looks like we've lost that
arm this arms gone
most of these legs have been like
stripped the thing is is that this this
is what holds the lower leg in place and
that's ripped open which means the whole
leg is gone whereas you know actually we
can probably use the top half again
smashed is good yeah the goosh goosh
it's made of a rubber smush is that from
where the wheel was set yes so this is
where the wheel was and the force of the
airbag pushing down into the ground has
caused the look that you can even read
it like the rubber that says SS p9 300
it's backwards because obviously this
smooth it's smushed
it's obviously just mirrored so are you
glad that it wasn't you in most place
are you do you mean am I glad that my
leg hasn't come on I need a new Gooch
you imagine if I'd walked in after you
were on it and you were the exact same
you walked over to your battery like oh
no my battery oh well maybe we can work
on repairing him when using him in a
future video but we'll put them in or
put them in temporary retirement so
don't try that with a mannequin or a
human oops
sure it's so good that you didn't last
one episode make sure you subscribe to
the slow mo guys my second channel and
on social media and in memory of old
slow mo 1.0 give that Bell a little ring
yeah it was in his honor
tribute I'm gonna go and pick that dent
in the wall I'm gonna get some superglue
and try and fix them
[Music]